okay wait we got to do the thing yeah
we're doing it again we're doing it
again third time here we go can we talk
to you use it can we talk to him we were
doing this you were pitching a now
they're doing it because of us okay the
mandalorian is happening not only are
you directing an episode yeah yeah but
you're also playing a droid who is not a
GT not ig-88 as many people have
speculated IG eleven but still bounty
hunter droid and the list and as I sit
inside in the room
finally IG droids have got
representation on screen and their story
gets to be told and because for too long
they've been misunderstood and
misrepresented it's very important robot
power I can ask you a quick question
about Thor love and thunder because
natalie portman is Thor how did you a
thought I'm still the other Thor the
original form yeah most people are
saying female Thor and I'm like I got to
cut that out I got no she's not called
female for yeah but in the comics she's
called The Mighty Thor and that's it
comes from that that they're coming
around
yeah I couldn't be more happy and
excited but how they have this path
heading out thanks so much
great to see you